[Música]
revisamos los titulares de la prensa
internacional con rosa pérez más de
euros a bienvenida feliz lunes iniciamos
semana entonces con argentina porque
volvemos a repasar la prensa de ese país
como lo hicimos al viernes pero ahora
conociendo los resultados de las
elecciones primarias amos con tres
medios de comunicación el clarín la
nación y página/12 rosa buenos días raúl
feliz lunes exacto hemos seleccionado
las mismas cabeceras y vamos a ver lo
que destacan aunque como siempre tras
una jornada electoral las lecturas son
múltiples y también los análisis no pero
empezamos por clarín que señala el
golpeado el presidente habló de nueva
etapa y busca acordar un plano económico
con la oposición entre otras cosas
recordemos en el marco de la
renegociación del pago de la deuda
argentina con el fondo monetario
internacional por otro lado también en
la carta del editor señala el
oficialismo perdió pero intenta simular
que no ha pasado nada se entiende
esperaba una paliza electoral y sólo fue
una derrota importante que no pudo
evitar por otro lado la nación destaca
la supuesta caída del kirchnerismo
dentro del peronismo
y citamos también juntos por el cambio
obtuvo una victoria nítida a pesar de
eso alberto fernández celebra un triunfo
y llama a un acuerdo nacional en el que
no es seguro que esté cristina kirchner
y terminamos con página/12 donde la
ilustración es muy clara ahora la
veremos en este gráfico cuesta arriba
2023 de cara a las presidenciales y esta
nueva etapa del mandato de alberto
fernández con muchas más dificultades y
un medio que no hemos señalado en este
gráfico pero que vamos a comentar ahora
con otro tema es el país que por otro
lado destaca la entrada de la
ultraderecha en el congreso argentino a
través de la fuerza la libertad que
entra con cinco escaños en la cámara
baja vamos a hacer ahora entonces un
resumen de lo que fue la cob 26 en
glasgow rosa lo que nos queda de revista
de prensa porque como sabemos terminó
este viernes vamos a empezar con el país
como le estaba comentando una editorial
no no basta con una cumbre de compromiso
exacto vemos a que el país continúa
usando su editorial para recordar y
criticar en cierto modo esta cumbre de
glasgow uno diciendo que fue en cierto
momento en cierta medida decepcionante
porque dice no hace justicia al momento
de urgencia que vivimos y entre otras
cosas lo achaca a como los intereses
geoestratégicos económicos y políticos
pasan por delante de la urgencia
climática y lamenta que las evidencias
científicas ni el movimiento de la
sociedad civil hayan servido para que
los intereses financieros globales se
muevan hacia lo que es la economía verde
vamos a orar con de gharyan india fue
criticada acerca del carbón en el 26
pero el villano de la verdad era la
injusticia climática este artículo lo
hizo análisis petersen exacto es un
artículo redactado desde delhi y lo que
señala es que en cierto modo india y a
la posición de los países pobres o
llamados en vías de desarrollo respecto
a sus compromisos para frenar el cambio
climático se usan un poco como cabeza de
turco
por lo que es la injusticia climática
dice los débiles compromisos de la india
respecto a dejar de lado el carbón es
sólo una ilustración de la falta de
alternativas que tiene este país que
recordemos que depende en un 70 por
ciento del uso de esta materia prima del
carbón y dice sin embargo eeuu cuando
dejó de lado el carbón lo sustituyó
prácticamente por completo por lo que es
el gas natural y no se le exige del
mismo modo que imponga alternativas para
dejar de lado esta fuente energética
seguimos hablando de india vamos con el
time of india' un life de las medidas
acerca de la nube de contaminación que
estábamos hablando también en el
noticiero exacto este medio indio en
inglés pues está haciendo un seguimiento
minuto a minuto de lo que está
sucediendo con esta nube de polución
bajo la que viven ya los habitantes de
la capital de india que recordemos con
20 millones de personas el recimiento en
ella es también la más contaminada del
planeta y tras decretar el cierre de las
escuelas que entró en vigor este mismo
lunes y que las autoridades pidieran
también el teletrabajo para que
a las que les resulte posible se están
planteando también las autoridades
decretar el confinamiento por la
polución una medida que estaría
orientada sobre todo a atajar las
emisiones contaminantes pero es una
medida que recordemos no tendría
precedentes y cerramos rosa con una
encuesta de eivissa news y el washington
post sobre la percepción de los
estadounidenses respecto al cambio
climático interesante cuál es la
precisión de las estadounidenses bueno
vemos aquí tres preguntas representadas
en este gráfico la primera ahora cuando
la ampliaremos lo veremos mejor es como
de serio es el problema del cambio
climático para eeuu y vemos que un 57
por ciento de los encuestados responde
que es muy serio mientras que un 31 por
ciento responde que no en serio por otro
lado qué opinan los estadounidenses de
las políticas del gobierno para reducir
la emisión de gases de efecto
invernadero vemos que un 70% apoya estas
medidas frente a un 24% que se opone a
ellas y cerramos con esta pregunta el
gobierno debería y vemos que un 45 por
ciento
y tomar medidas inmediatas frente a un
49% que dice esperar a más evidencia a
raúl yo no sé qué más podemos esperar
dios mío qué más evidencia necesitamos
rosa muchísimas gracias entonces por
esta revista de prensa del lunes
iniciando semana nos vemos mañana con
más por lo pronto vamos ahora a ir con
nuestro primer invitado del día
[Música]